UP A LITTLE BIT.
IN THE NEUTRALAL PERIOD END
TO END.
CROSS-ICE PASS ASIDE.
GAUNCE GETS IT BACK.
HE OPENED THE SCORING FOR THE
JACKETS IN P HERE BIG REBOUND
OFF THE RIGHT PAD AND AWAY GOES
LAINE, LAINE TRYING TO
HANDING HERE TO HAYES CROSS ICE,
RIGHT  BLUE JACKETS ON THEF THE
PUCK, IT'S
NYQUIST.
IT'S GOING TO
UNABLE TO CORRAL CROSS-ICE
PASS AND LAINE ALERTLY WITH A
STICK IN THE LANEE PUCK IS PLAY
PERIOD.
>> JodS IT UP AND N.
NICE PLAY A LOT OF MOVEMENT.
KU
POSSESSION OF THE PUCK AND AS
THEY TRY TO GET IT UP YOU CAN F.
SILLINGER CRUISING THROUGH THE
NEUTRAL ZONE PHILADELPHIA,
WITH A OF
THIS SECOND PERIOD.
YORK SLIDES IT AHEAD, HAYES DOWN
THE, AND HE'LL COVER
UP.
SHORT-HANDED.
BJORKSTRAND DANCING IN.
OLIVER UP THERE WITH KONECNY,
FEEDS KONECNY.
KO
FROM THE CORNER, HAYES, KEVIN
DEADLINE IN THE CLAUDE GIROUX
TRADE. ON THAT LEFT WING
TIPPETT DROP FEED, ACROSS THE
MIDDLE OF THE ICE AND THAT JUSU
JACKETS DUMP IT DEEP AND A
LITTTT HERE
IN THE EARLY MINUTESTIPPETT, KN
AIR, PLAYED ALONG THE RIGHT WING
WALL, SENEN NATE
THOMPSON.
THOMPSON CONTINUES TO PRESSURE.
.
I KNOW THEY WERE ON THE P PS SE
PHILADELPHIA TERRITORY.
CARSON MEYER ON THE  FLYERS, CAS
WAS RIGHT THERE ON THEK OR PUT
IT IN WITH SPEED AND GET SHOT B.
HAYES WAITS IN THE HIGH SLOT ON
COUPLE FEET BEHIND NOW.
>> Jeff:.
>> Jeff: IF
THEY'LL LOOK AT IT AGAIN HERE,
AS WE ON THE RIGHT
SIDE.
DANFORTH THE RIGHT-HANDED
SHOOTER USUALLY TAKES ELVIS COUP
UP.
>> Jeff: SO